that's Kourtney Kardashian david dobrik
and right there in the middle tic TOCs
newest star Mason Disick yep over the
weekend the oldest of Kourtney's kids
made his debut on the Ashe and honestly
he is made for it the help of his mom
and his moves of course Mase
already has over 65 thousand followers
under his belt he's even getting advice
from YouTube mega stars david dobrik who
by the way has almost nine million
followers on tick-tock hey guys I'm here
with Maci I'm going to teach him how to
tick tock famous relative check auntie
Khloe is also here to support she shared
a video of her nephew telling fans to
follow his account and they won't be
disappointed because in true Kardashian
fashion the 10 year old entertains just
by showing off his closet so far Mason
has posted a handful of videos including
this one featuring port rain safe north
and P Jacuzzi jacuzzi the water for
dinner on
speaking of Northwest Kim and Kanye's
six year old adorable daughter has
already appeared on tick-tock in the
past at the top of this year she joined
her pal Kaden Mills and made the cutest
videos showing off their skills
[Music]
I mean really can they be any cooler
with so much budding talent on their
hands et caught up with Kim Khloe and
Kourtney last October to see who's most
likely to catch the momager bug not me
you think me yeah I think I could do it
with Jojo see what that's what if that's
what they wanted to do young yes but
sometimes I think as a mom I can say yes
to things that they really want to do in
the moment and I think they're ready
because they asked me so many times but
I think I think I gotta like chill I
think that's like my new thing is like
not doing it yeah even when they want to
do it because ultimately right now it's
just a phase
[Music]